international soccer is making its debut
at a legion stadium this weekend fans
getting ready for us to face mexico on
sunday
traveling from all over to prepare for
the game here in las vegas
sasha loftus joining us from allegiant
stadium with more on all the excitement
we spoke with quite a few fans here in
las vegas today who are just
counting the hours until the u.s faces
mexico
for the concacaf gold cup final the
international soccer showdown is the
latest big event to take place at a
legion stadium
now fans will be required to wear masks
as the mandate here in nevada was
reinstated
last night at midnight the usb katar
thursday night to face defending
champion mexico
this matchup sold out in just over an
hour
those we spoke with shared what they're
most looking forward to
even though it's a rivalry thing a sport
but at the end it still brings you know
two communities together that are
mixed in already here in the city of las
vegas so it's great i am happy to see
soccer in las vegas
i am excited for sunday mexico usa
the final i hope mexico
the gold cup championship is held every
two years but this is the first time
we're having it here in las vegas so
pretty exciting
the kickoff here at allegion stadium is
at 5 30 p.m
on sunday make sure to stay with 8 news
now all weekend for the latest sports
coverage
reporting from allegiant stadium tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now
sasha thanks after soccer the first las
vegas raiders preseason game against
seattle is august 14th at a legion
stadium
then wrestling with the wwe summerslam a
week later
followed by guns and roses on the 27th
of august it's a friday night
unlv takes on the eastern washington
eagles
on september 2nd